wir kommen aus der Hauptstadt wir kommen
aus Berlin ich bin hier um morgen eine
große futur zu drehen top foodsports in
Berlin ich freue mich sehr darauf aber
ich muss mich erstmal stärken und wie
macht man das am besten wenn man ganz
entspannt in sein Hotelzimmer chillen
will ganz einfach man bestellt sich was
zu essen genau das werden wir machen und
nicht irgendwas sondern das
bestbewertete Essen in Berlin zumindest
von meinem Standort aus Berlin nicht
bestellen aber das tun wir jetzt erstmal
aber ganz kurz während wildes Setup
Zusammenwirken an jede Lampe wie auch
immer ich bin sehr happy ich freue mich
richtig auf die Zeit hier in Berlin
sollen wir noch bestellen
ich bin sehr gespannt also ich weiß ne
gerade als Kölner muss ich neidlos
anerkennen dass in Berlin auf jeden Fall
glaube ich das krasseste Essen gibt in
Deutschland also zumindest die größte
Vielfalt und dementsprechend bin ich
gespannt was ist das beste bewertete
hier in Berlin hoffentlich jetzt nicht
irgendwie sowas oder so vielleicht
müssen wir dann was kippen okay dann
wollen wir mal gemeinsam schauen ich
gehe auf Restaurants und es lädt oh
Rieser chicken davon habe ich schon viel
gehört habe ich noch nie gegessen aber
ich glaube das ist sehr bel jetzt hier
in Berlin 8,0 10 mögliche Punkte gibt es
komm wir schnacken einfach nicht lang
wir sind zu viert hier das heißt wir
können auch ein bisschen was verdrücken
und wir Filtern jetzt nach bestbewertet
679 verschiedene Restaurant gibt es
Platz 1 parsam Baklava einfach ein
Baklava Spot hoffentlich habe ich nicht
nur Baklava na wobei sonst ist unser
Dessert die besten Baklava in Berlin das
ist schon wieder krass das ist schon
Statement auf jeden Fall es gibt auch
wirklich nur Baklava
rate mal was die Portionsgröße ist 12 1
kg ein Kilogramm Baklava an allem ein
Kilogramm Alter was meine Ernst okay
Leute
wir können das Verstehen jetzt nicht ein
Kilo Baklava okay bist romantstein das
Platz 2 das ist Platz 2 Salat mit Feta
15 80 Salat mit Maultaschen 15 50 Salat
mit Thunfisch 15 80 also sowas machen ne
ist halt das bestbewertete Restaurant
hier in Berlin wir bestellen da und ich
bin mir sicher wir werden dich
enttäuscht so aber es ist auf jeden Fall
nicht das mit dem ich gerechnet hätte
wir gucken am besten bei den Gerichten
Königsberger Klopse sind sehr beliebt
16,50 soll ich Königsberger Stellen in
Berlin im Hotel
bestellung ist raus wir wechseln jetzt
einfach mal die liefer-app von Volt zu
ubereez und gucken was da das Beste ist
damit wir auch wirklich das
bestbewertete Essen in Berlin bestellen
hier sehen wir auf jeden Fall schon ein
paar andere Sachen ich glaube über X ist
relativ stark hier und ich Filter
einfach mal direkt nach Bewertung let's
go oberster Platz ist ein anderes Bistro
ein anderes Bistro Bistro Partys geht 13
Bewertungen aber auch nur knusprige Ente
mit rotem Curry erst durch big Döner
Kebab im Brot danach
knusprige Ente mit erdnuss-soße also
nimmst du nicht übel das nehmen wir
einfach nicht okay die haben 57
Bewertung des Platz drei oder so deshalb
auch vallett the club kitchen West
Ingwer Soja Lachsfilet Kürbis Ragout
greenbol Chemie das das ist schon ein
bisschen Berlin von der Speisekarte
nicht so diese progressive Küche so
Fusion mehrere Sachen miteinander
verbunden passt damit geröstet das heißt
feature sehr geil das klingt echt gut
von der Speisekarte her checke ich das
hier auf jeden Fall mehr dass das so ein
besonderer außergewöhnlicher Laden ist
in viele Leute sehr feiern ich will die
passt damit geröstet das heißt ich finde
passt dazu liefern ist auch immer
relativ schwierig so wegen dem Garpunkt
der Nudeln das sieht schon was Zucchini
Zitrone Minze Chili Parmesan klingt auch
geil ja bestellung ist raus wir wechseln
noch ein letztes Mal die App wir sind
bei Lieferando und gucken einfach direkt
beste wertet komm zack um 754 Ergebnisse
Burger okay okay da steht zwar Angebot
aber ich glaube das ist eher so ein nee
gesponsert die wir müssen die
gesponserten auslassen und dann ist
Nummer 1 Berlin
okay dass ich nicht geil danke schön
eigentlich wollte ich gerade die
Bestellung abschicken aber man kann als
Dessert frittierter Schokoriegel
wahlausweis
auch nicht Alter Laien habe ich so lange
nicht gegessen ich nehme Leim das war
die letzte Bestellung wir warten jetzt
bis alles ankommt ich habe großen Hunger
ich freue mich sehr bis gleich die erste
Bestellung ist da und es ist die zweite
die wir getätigt haben 14 Minuten hat
das von Bestellung bis hier oben im
Zimmer gedauert und ich bin sogar noch
runter gegangen und habe es geholt
schauen wir mal was uns erwartet also
sehr gut zuschauen
Alter mächtige Portion Hebamme hoch
gerade
nach Berlin haben eine geile Zeit ich
teste bisschen Essen danke für das
sofort auf jeden Fall lass mal bisschen
extra Supporter wenn ihr die futur sehen
wollt und viele gewünscht Eli hat mir
geschrieben dass sie gerne machen soll
gucken wir uns mal die Pasta an alright
wow guck mal hier so dieser Parmesan ist
halt so von der Kondens in der Box ein
bisschen angeschwitzt und so aber ich
glaube das ist wirklich meckern auf
allerhöchsten Niveau dass das so schnell
geklappt hat das richtig wird es riecht
interessant es riecht vor allem so ein
bisschen nach Zitrone ne das ist so das
erste was man in die Nase bekommt ja
eine weiße Soße eine helle Soße Zucchini
Streifen auf jeden Fall etwas was ich
noch nicht gegessen habe als jemand der
sehr viel ist sehr viel probiert freue
ich mich darüber immer probiert als
allererstes mal wie die Nudeln sind ob
die gar sind ob die Übergabe sind
crazy boah die Soße ist richtig lecker
das hat so ein bisschen was von so einem
warmen Nudelsalat ja durch diese Säure
halten dass man normalerweise nicht in
so einer Pasta Soße erwarten würde also
ich muss echt sagen würde ich in Berlin
leben wäre das nicht das letzte Mal dass
ich bei dem Laden bestellt habe ist es
besser als alles was ich jemals in Köln
bestellt habe ich weiß gar nicht genau
dann irgendwas erinnert mich vielleicht
so ein Teil Nudelsalat aber halt nicht
teil oh oh oh
also ich würde sagen hohe Bewertung
garantiert verdient sehr geil ich finde
Präsentation deshalb keine sehr fotogene
Pasta aber geschmacklich super muss auf
jeden Fall einen neuen Form Komma sein
mit glatte 10 gibt es glaube ich nicht
aber neuneinhalb von 10 ich finde es
richtig gut ich bin gespannt was die
anderen so bringen weil das hat schon
nicht falsch verstehen die Latte auf
jeden Fall hoch gehängt
als zweites kommt die erste Bestellung
an und das erwartet ein Veganer
Schokokuchen okay
dann äh rot wahrscheinlich hast du schon
mal Königsberger Klopse gegessen ich
habe sogar bei 4k für die Twins von
World Wohnzimmer habe ich mal äh
Königsberger Klopse gemacht okay und wir
gucken ja Kapern sind drin und also
sorry auch hier Königsberger Klopse sind
jetzt auch nicht das schönste Gericht
aller Zeiten aber dass das kommt wenn
man das beste bewertete bestellt in
Berlin finde ich irgendwie aufregend
also ich meine gerade eben gerade eben
hat uns ja der Geschmack überzeugt ne
ich bin gespannt wie es hier ist es ist
halt wirklich vielleicht so ein Ding wie
wir meinten ne die Berliner so den die
haben alles da gibt's alles was du dir
nur wünschen kannst gehst ins kardinien
die Feinkost Abteilung da kann es gibt
solche nichts was nicht gibt vielleicht
hast du einfach Bock auf Königsberger
Klopse da müssen sie nur auf jeden Fall
gut sein so ich bin kein Königsberger
Klopse Experte aber ich kann sagen ob es
mir gut schmeckt gucken wir als
allererstes mal Kartoffeln
toller gab Punkt
irgendwas wäre auch irgendwie komisch
beim Wettbewerb im Restaurant diese Soße
die Königsberger Klopse Soße ich glaube
die basiert auf einem Mehlschwitze oder
so ich habe es echt lange nicht gemacht
die ist geil weil da sind Kapern mit
dabei auch hier wieder ne sache liebt
das schmeckt soweit gut 16,50 € teuer
wenn es halt richtige Königsberger
Klopapier aber wir probieren
also genauso wie man Königsberger Klopse
erwartet ich finde es irgendwie ein
bisschen gerade zu essen weil ich würde
mir wirklich niemals eigentlich
Königsberger Klopse bestellen Bistro
erwartet man und bist Stroh bekommt man
das ist jetzt nicht abgefahrene Küche
oder so sondern das ist wirklich
Hausmannskost wer das bestellt erwartet
ihr aber auch genau das und deshalb
finde ich eigentlich fair und auch gut
so eine Sache gibt es noch zu testen und
zwar den veganen Schokokuchen sehr
gespannt darauf können wir machen das
ganz unkompliziert und noch beißen
einfach rein weil ich habe keine beste
mehr
positiv überrascht ja schön saftig sehr
schokoladig ist wenn man an so einem
klassisches Bistro denkt eigentlich
schon fast verrückt dass sie ein veganen
Kuchen können oder weil in so einem
richtigen Bistro erwartet man eigentlich
dass man so angebrüllt wird wenn man was
vegast verstellt hat für uns sieben von
zehn machen wir weiter mit dem Burrito
auf den ich sehr gespannt bin hallo
kommen wir zur letzten Bestellung
frittierter Schokoriegel mit Vanillesoße
aber warum können wir uns gleich erstmal
richtiger Apparat hier jetzt wird's hart
auch für mich persönlich weil ich
vergleich das mit bayeria in Köln und
Bay Area dazu gemacht deshalb kann ich
vielleicht jetzt meine Burrito Gelüste
zufriedenstellend nur noch in Berlin
Stellen er sieht auf jeden Fall nicht so
prall gefüllt aus wie ein Burritos war
er sieht aber trotzdem aus weil das sind
diese Riesen 32 cm Durchmesser tortiert
die so relativ dünn sind und so weich so
klebrig ich weiß was du meinst das ist
schon mal geil aber
okay
dem Reis kann man es glaube ich ansehen
sehr geschmacksintensiv auf jeden Fall
der erste bist den ich hatte man hat ja
immer relativ viel Tortilla gerade an
der Oberseite war ein bisschen trocken
und was unfair ist normalerweise sitze
ich immer zu Hause mit so einer Flasche
hotshots und Schütt mir dann immer noch
Hotspots drauf schmeckt aber schon echt
gut der Reis ist wirklich besonders ich
höre dir aber an das ist auch keine
Erleuchtung ist oder es ist nicht wir
haben ja mehr erwartet beim besten so
oder ist jetzt natürlich auch nicht muss
man sagen besser ist in Köln ist immer
für mich persönlich war es halt sehr
sehr gut ne aber es hat auch krass
gewesen immer ich finde es nicht also
eigentlich habe ich dir ein bisschen
Unrecht getan weil ich kenne halten
Kranken Burrito das ist ein Kranker
Berufung also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie
keinen Vergleich hätte und so normal
irgendwie nur so aus alitos buritos
Essen oder kennen würde dann würde ich
vielleicht sagen wow das ist ja nix
level was ist ein super gut also keine
Frage gute Bewertung safe verdient aber
rückblickend was vielleicht die Pasta
für mich die Zeit sieht schon fast dabei
ich auch wir haben die auch noch mit
Genuss aufgegessen und ich muss sagen
die hat so die warten
außergewöhnlichsten geht am meisten für
mich persönlich Berlin symbolisiert aber
eine Sache haben wir gelernt es macht
nicht immer Sinn nach dem besten
Bewertungen zu gehen deshalb seid euch
sicher ich gehe nicht nur nach bewertung
für die Top food Spots die wir morgen
drehen und testen werden ich habe mit
Leuten gesprochen ich habe mir selbst
Gedanken gemacht das wird richtig wild
deshalb lass mein like auf diesem Video
da wer dann kommt die ganz bald extrem
bald aber hier haben wir noch stehen
dort ein bisschen probieren
das sieht so falsch aus
ja klassisch mexikanische Nachspeise
deshalb Burrito gut Tagessieger die
Pasta danke fürs zuschauen wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Mal wieder bis dahin
macht's gut ciao